From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
My name is Emily Crosby and I'm here this morning on December 1, 2015 with Mrs. Jeanette Smith and Mrs. Rolani Branch.
And we're at the University of Southern Mississippi Center for Oil History and Cultural Heritage, which has been helping with these interviews.
And this interview is part of the Civil Rights History Project, co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
So good morning and welcome and thank you. Good morning, good morning.
Thank you. I wonder if we could start if you could each just say a little bit about when you were born, where you were born and your family?
I guess you're starting this move.
I was born in Jones County, free state of Jones. I was born January 1, 1940.
And basically I have property up there now, I have the family property. So my heritage is deep there.
And eventually I would like to move back to So-So.
It has so many fun memories. I had one of my parents. They really raised us right. And on the circumstances being a product of the free state of Jones, parents didn't teach us to hate anyone.
And that was a good thing for me, especially going through the movement.
I stayed in Jacksonville a while, two years, then I moved back to So-So, finished high school and met my husband.
I married him and moved to your dad's birth in 1959, January.
You know, not everybody's going to know about the free state of Jones. Can you tell us about that?
Captain Newton Knight was able to meet my great-great-grandmother Rachel, his grandfather, and bought her as a slave.
He fell in love with her. And he figured that he would just establish his own state. He didn't believe in segregation.
He married her, and he had a family by her. And my grandfather was a proud of that family.
So he wasn't successful in establishing his free state of Jones. So he deserted the Confederacy and joined the union.
He succeeded differently if I'm like a Confederacy. He succeeded. And there is a movie coming out.
And in general, about it, Dr. Biden was doing like you. She wrote a book on the free state of Jones.
And what that book does, it documents my people.
So in Mississippi, where we think of things as sort of black and white, right?
It was never black and white.
And I think this area is one of the places that really shows some of the complexity of that.
Yeah, all right. They did. And then that's one reason because the mixture of the races, that's why black people have so much life.
Because they gave all of you a rematch.
And that's the land that's still there.
But it comes from my mother's side, which is the same type of situation.
My grandfather was Indian and white. And you know, just a mixture of both sides by racial people.
What kind of work did your family do in your parents?
My mother was the black nurse. And my father was a contractor, a carpenter.
And he did farm and he had his own land. He was hired out. He'd build a lot of all-so and the helicopter homes there for the doctors and lawyers and people like that.
It was independent.
I want to come back and follow up with Ms. Branch. Could you tell us about why you were born in your family?
I was born the first of September, 1941. We're of the same age group.
I was born here in Hattiesburg, 7-11 Whitney Street in my grandmother's house.
It was a three-room shotgun house with outdoor pretty.
We had sidewalks. So at that time you paid for them if you wanted to get sidewalks and families.
Did you pay the city or did you pay somebody for the rent?
You paid the city and they installed.
So the street on which I was born had a church on the corner.
Miss Emma Campbell, who I don't know where Miss Emma came from, but Miss Emma was even lighter in skin color than Jeanette.
And Mr. Kelly, I think, was some way tied up in that.
There are several little communities around Hattiesburg where there were situations like Jeanette's parents.
And they had children.
I was born here in Hattiesburg. I had one brother born here in Hattiesburg even though they're 10 of us, 10 children.
And I too come from family out around Prentice, Mississippi, a little village called Mount Carmel, Mississippi.
And we went back and looked at the books and my great grandparents actually bought that property.
40 acres. Each one, they bought 80 acres. Nobody gave that 40 acres in a mule.
That never, never was a true thing. It might have been on the books, but it wasn't something that actually happened.
But land was divided up in 40 acres. I lived between Hattiesburg and Mount Carmel, with the school between Hattiesburg and Mount Carmel.
And I'm a person who, I would say I would beg to differ with you about the civil rights history.
They're really, we are making history today because civil rights is still a problem. We're a wife.
And I don't believe in different races of mankind. We're all mankind. We're not all men, but we're all mankind.
I would love to have it before I die, where people are like Jeanette and I.
We were never taught to hate people because when you went to a funeral, there were blonde and blue eyed people there who were your closest of kids.
So you grew up with this in your head and I really never knew a difference until the death of Emma Jill.
And that I was in Chicago at that time. I was a teenager. And up until then, just did not realize the hatred and hate.
I knew there were differing communities, but the lady who lived next to my great grandmother, who was married to a gentleman who did not have, but since I would say he drank and he didn't take care of his family properly.
He didn't farm properly. And she was what we call today white Caucasian of European extraction.
Po white folks, some folks call them. Po crackers, some people call them. But she would come over and help my great grandmother get food in and can and pee, shell.
So my great grandmother would give food and meat to her to take the feed the host of young ones as they say that she had.
I husband was no good, but she would come and help my great grandmother. So I grew up not really understanding because there were situations like that.
Was that kind of interaction in community? Was that the same in town as it was out in the country?
I think in town, women of color worked in the big houses, in the houses. And it was many times. It was a reciprocal relationship.
You were able to carry home the food that was left over, the clothes that were too little left over when you wanted to buy a house,
Miss Ann could call the bank or her husband could call the bank and say, you know, give, give, give, give soons on so that long for that house.
So there were there were relationships. But the badness was there. I think I think the movie, the help, tells the story better than anything I've ever seen.
It's for the meanness. What kind of work did your parents do? My father was a farmer.
He died when I was 14 and he died in Chicago. He thought he couldn't get a job. There were no jobs. You can be hired out by someone.
I can remember picking cotton, sitting on what they call a slide pulled by a mule from one field to another.
And my mother was a housewife. We went to Chicago. In Chicago my father worked at the first job he had was tip-top bakery. And I'm sure it was just scrap work.
My mother's first job I remember was at Brock Candy Company. And my mother was so fair they hired her thinking she was white. And she didn't have better sense than to go sit and have lunch with the person, the one woman in the building who was color.
She would go and sit and have lunch and finally the supervisor said to her one day, why do you go sit with her and have lunch? And that inward. And my mother said because I'm one of those. And she was fired on the spot.
And I would have kept the job to help feed my children because we lived much better in Mississippi than we ever did in Chicago.
Was that because you could raise your food? You had land, you could raise your food. You had relatives.
You had family and everybody in town was kin one way or the other.
I was going to ask what it was like for you to move to Chicago from Mississippi.
It wasn't that much different as a child. There were very few children of European extraction in my class, very few.
There were none here except all of those little high yellow ones that were moved or even the blonde green-eyed cousins.
But it was much different. When we went to Oak Park outside of Chicago or Wineca Illinois on the train, the school would take you on the school trip.
You would go on the L train and just ride so far and get off and come back.
And you would see all these big beautiful homes and communities.
But you didn't internalize it as something against you. You just figured that your parents couldn't afford it.
But we did own our home in Chicago. My dad had bought a home. In fact, he bought two and he got sick.
He had some type of blood dyscracia. And my mother was pregnant and we lost our home and we ended up in the park homeless furniture in the alley.
What did your family do?
We lived in the park for a while. We were just homeless folks trying to find some place to sleep at night.
And that was usually one room and everybody piled into that one room.
I would never take my children back to a city.
This is a city. But I'm now able to own and buy and sell.
But I would not. People. I see people in, let's say, out of Africa and out of the Middle East trying to get to Europe.
Some are getting there and finding out the streets are not paid with gold.
And it's better at home. Even if you had to mash the corn by hand, it's better at home.
I want to come back to what you said about Hamid Till. But first I was wondering if you could both tell me some of the things that you learned in school and from your families that you think were important.
I grew up in a family, seven-year-old, seven-year-old, we had our own school. We were called the lightning girl.
Even though our relatives were dark, you had to fight racism within both races.
And you had the terrorists that clook up clean. It was just that we were descendants of Newton Night.
So it didn't know about a father, a note. Because he didn't take no stuff he didn't bother with people.
But when my mother married my daddy, they called him a scrooge, and I'm crazy, he said, my children are going to public school.
We're not going to isolate them. They got to live in a real world. They got to live with their relatives, some of my daughter, and some of her alike.
We didn't have anything to do with this. So what we're going to do, we're going to live within what's going on. You're going to accept what's going on.
You're not going to have any hatred against people that are dark upon you and white people. You're going to live in a real world. You're going to love everybody.
My people were Christian people. They didn't believe in hatred and stuff like that.
And if you open-minded and our people had traveled, and I had never traveled that much, but I did.
But I had relatives who had been everywhere. And we're very important people. And you have struggles of terrorists that are going on from the beginning of time.
That's why I'm just so appalled that I'm making such an issue on these immigrants.
You know, to me as a little girl, I always wonder, how can they come in here and take this country from any slaughtered him and kill him in this their country?
Then I found out, California, they did the same thing. It's just people that conquered. And then my mother would teach me to read the Bible. It was going on back then. Same thing, brother guess what?
That's saying in the world that has nothing to do. They don't even know why they don't. So then as a little girl, I ask, I have so many questions.
Why would this man know that it was illegal? Married as well as she was a mixed woman. Married her and tried to establish his own country and bring about children that are going to be faced with all this hatred among both races.
You're not accepted anywhere. So I remember growing up, the street you see now, I had them all done. But I tended. I tended my hair just as soon as I could. I got along because my mother, my first cousin had a beauty college. I brought about Jackson State. So I learned how to cover it up.
I thought of myself. I look pole cat. I'm just strict. I'm just messed up. And then my mother would get on my case. Why? You ask all this person. I said, well, my mom just wanted to know.
She said, we don't talk about that. We're trying to out legal that. I don't want you to go back in the past. You know, you didn't have anything to do with being more. You're a God's job.
So I kept pounding on there. I'm gotcha. I don't feel it having me feeling sorry to anyone. I get along with everyone. Those are just problems of the world. You've got terrorists all over the world. If I know, look me silly. Over there in Israel, it's not enough anyone. Same thing all over the world.
So I know that which my mother taught me as I get older, I know this. I'm Jesus Christ's child or whatever it is you believe in. My salvation is not about this world. It's somewhere else.
Do you know those questions you're asking in your sense of not belonging in the community? Do you remember sort of when and how you first had a sense of not belonging in the community? When that happened to you, how you understood that?
Well, first of all, they questioned my eyes. You know, you can tell a person is by racial. Mostly got the green eyes. They got those eyes. And they call me, I was a devil's child. I just spent in a good school.
Well, also, I lived exactly a mile from the school. I couldn't catch the birth of, I didn't want to fight my relatives. I walked the school a little morning. It was something about your hair. They pulled you. They did it. You're different. You know, you're not just woman. You're not getting out of here.
We still be called different marriage. So what I'm saying, what I mean, you're right about that. So what I'm saying, can I be just America? I want to be an American citizen. I don't want to be black or white. I do am out in America. You know, you know, and then you think about it within yourself and then you got to be very careful. You know, I want to offend them.
You can't be too I spoke because you don't feel someone. And I really don't want to do that. But it's very difficult when you are mixed. Very. Catch it all. It's when you're born. You know, you're different.
They call my mother butter gal because she was blonde. And her at the time, her stepfather was her stepfather. My grandmother was raped by the plantation owner.
And when she found out she was pregnant, she ran off from it's a little area out near Prenniss, Coffinchett. And she ran off to Hattiesburg.
She worked enough to buy a house. They were selling houses from World War I off of Camp Shelby. Little shotgun houses they had down there.
And they moved them from Camp Shelby up to Hattiesburg. So there would be just lines of real shotgun, rolls of shotgun houses. They'd stick them beside the railroad track anywhere.
She married my grandmother married what they call a cagin out of Southern Louisiana.
What what what at that time? What do they what made someone a cagin?
They were Frenchmen out of originally out of Newfoundland and they you know they loaded them down, shipped them down from Newfoundland to the Louisiana territory.
And the Native Americans. And I don't know which nation the Native Americans and Africans.
And they are still calling themselves cagins. They speak with a little accent. They live in those swamps. I'm not saying they're backward to anything. It's just that they they maintain that culture.
And my mother's father whom she called father. She sent him to my grandmother made a decision never to have another child after he was killed on the railroad. He worked on the railroad in 1932.
And that was a year when I did a little research when there were many men of color who were killed on the railroad. Now whether it was just purely accident or intentional, I don't know.
But my mother was an only child. And my grandmother would put a mole on top of her head and just cut her hair around like that and around the front.
And she would deliver the butter that my grandmother would make because my granddad had a cow, a pig that he'd keep down on the river, which was just quarter mile away.
So for my mother, she would not talk about the fact of who she was and how she came about. It was a taboo subject. And I went looking for a birth certificate for her. And the sad thing. I can't smile on this one.
The sad thing is that she lived until she was 67 and she never knew her real name. On birth certificate, it says Christine Holloway.
They mixed my grandmother's name, which was Phanimae Holloway. They took the old, mistook the old and made it in A or just didn't care or whatever. So she was born and died and never knew her name. But her name that we knew was Alpharenzia Elsie after her daddy, out of Louisiana.
And when we looked up Frank Elsie, she was the only child listed under him, even though he had been married before. And I don't know if there was a divorce or anything like that. It was very hard for my mother. She was like your family.
She was ostracized on both sides. If you had one drop, one 30 second, one 16, what they call black blood, you were black.
So you could be blonde and you can be blue eyed. But if there was a, as Mr. Carter would say, one in the wood pile, then you were that.
For me, I was dark enough. The only people who mistaked me are the, some people from Thailand or some of the Hawaiian islands, Fijians, Koreans. There's some dark skinned Koreans. And I get mistaken, especially by the men, if I'm walking on the street.
And I lived, I went to school part-time in New York City. And I found that those kinds of people who would talk to me in their language. And I would say, I'm sorry, I don't understand what you're saying. It was probably good. I didn't understand.
But I know that many people, and I straight my hair at that time, I don't straight my hair anymore. I just got to where I said, I have to love me, no matter what. And I love me all over.
I still own the property that my grandmother inherited. And so my daddy's dead. And it came to us, children. And we've maintained it. In fact, I have a daughter retiring next year. And I gave 12 acres to her. And she's going to build the house on her 12 acres.
And she's going back to the country like you.
Is anybody farm your land?
No, it's timber. But it's beautiful land. And I'm sure if you put some, my great-grandmother used to have her garden closest to the house. And then there were fields of corn and cotton and all kinds of vegetables.
And the smokehouse. And once a year, people would get together once or twice a year. The women would get together and do all the canning. And the men would get together in the fall and make syrup and smoke meat. And the women would make sausage.
So it was more community than what you have in a city.
You didn't have that.
Well, yes, you did. You had those, my uncle and I who had a store. But his daddy, his dad, his dad, his dad, it was Colonel Hall. Colonel Hall, Colonel Robert Hall. And my uncle Rowan were first cousins.
So him being green-eyed and very fair and blonde, he not only had the store in our village, he was even allowed to sell guns and ammunition, which was a law.
Blacks could not own hardwares. So they could, because they could get guns and ammunition. But he was allowed because he was who he was.
That's interesting. And that family on LMA married one of my uncles on my daddy's side. And on LMA, we were blonde and blue-eyed when she died. That she was in her late 60s.
So we were just humans. And you can't afford to hate anyone because then you hate yourself. And I usually don't use black and white.
Everyone here at the university knows I don't. And I think some people do things out of guilt because I know
that plaza. Have you seen the plaza? There's a plaza on campus. It has an Armstrong branch plaza. It's two blocks long. It's wide. It seats on both sides. The international building is on it because I had made a comment that I would love to have international building on the plaza.
He was put on the plaza. So I don't think they could do anything else for us. For 20, what 93 they started. The Armstrong branch lectures here.
I tell you got in watches and all kinds of pictures and things and dinners. But I would rather them use the money for scholarships and not things. Of course you can't blow down a building. And we've had some buildings blown down on this campus. I mean nobody.
I don't think a tornado had ever been through here before it was built. The school was built about a hundred years ago. But the tornado came through and really.
Recently. Yes. I remember. Yeah. It was recent. It was 2013. February 10, 2013.
I was in New York, but I remember. Now this is home for you. Well, Claymore County. Okay. So you're a Mississippi. And that's right. You did tell that.
I raised here. Came when I was eight. Okay. We haven't talked yet about the fact that you were one of the first students to integrate the University of Southern Mississippi.
So I wanted to give that context for what you were talking about with the branch plows and the lecture series. Well, we can.
Without people like her husband and her. And the things they did during the late 50s early 60s. People like Mr. Verna, Namor, Mr. Boren's.
There are just so many people who helped me helped us. Elaine Armstrong. Gwendolyn Elaine Armstrong. That's her name.
Gwendolyn was six years younger than me. She graduated from the same high school I did. Rowan, which was the colored high school.
She wanted to go to school at home. She wanted to stay at home because her mother was handicapped. And she felt it was best for her to stay at home and not go off to all corner Jackson State.
And since Ole Miss had integrated, quote, unquote, integration never really came about.
They had to be the first school, the politics behind it. They had to be the first one in poor James Meredith really caught Elle doing that. And people died. And people were injured.
And the devil showed his face on that camera.
By the time we came here in 65, we didn't have any problems at all. I think I got called the nigga one time. And the ball field at that time was where the business school is out on the highway there, off the service road.
That's where we went and had Jim. I'll never forget the first time I went into the Jim building to change clothes.
I was putting on my shorts. And there was a big mirror. When I came up, I could see these girls standing behind me in the mirror, then watching for my tail.
Because some people actually thought we had tails. And I guess they had been reared up with that lie. And I just smile.
You don't pick a fight over something so silly. They could see I had no tail.
Maybe they thought I cut it off. I don't know. But they alphabetized us in class.
So I was always one of the last ones. If you're looking the yearbook, you'll see. I won almost the last page there.
There were a few people maybe who would come out of Europe, had Z's or V's or I was a Y.
And so there might have been some Z's after me. But in the classroom, I was usually V lasted.
I was just in instructors, just ignored us. We were just there.
Elaine and I never really had a class together. She was an A. Armstrong. So she was usually up front in the class. And I was in the back.
And if you look at the yearbook, you can see, they made us all the same color. I mean, you can't find us by color.
No, not at all. The gentleman who was our advisor was Dr. Gougher Fish. He was in science department.
Dr. Fish in a meeting with Dr. McCain, who was the president. And he had been told if he allowed anyone to come here, they would shut down the governor, who was Ross Barnett at that time, said they would close down the school.
I should say that we're actually in the McCain library here.
Yes, we are actually. And this is President McCain, I think he's my friend.
This is President McCain. He lived in what we call the Ogletree House. The Ogletree gave a lot of money. I mean, that's the only way you get something.
Of course, with your name on it out here. But, except my case, the Department of Transportation, King, who was a senator, King at the time.
Signed off on over a million dollars to put in this plaza. I think they did it out of guilt. But, it doesn't matter. It establishes the fact that we were here in their bronze plaques in the ground on both ends.
But, Dr. McCain had stated that he could not let anyone come, and that's why he didn't let Clyde Kenart come.
And what happened to Clyde was criminal, and everyone involved should have gone to jail.
But, at that time, you could just walk up to someone and shoot them. You weren't going to jail. You weren't even going to... I mean, if they had a trial, it was a mockery.
And then you said, you don't like to use black and white, but what you're talking about here, right? Is it the white person killing a black person?
Yes. There's a video of the guy, and they showed it right in that video. It was one of those eyes on the bride.
Where this guy walks up in McComb, Mississippi, white, and just shot, put blank, a black guy who was going and registered to vote.
I know, I think the state representative, the W.S. Herbert Lee.
Yes. I don't think anything... I don't even think they had a trial.
They had a coroner's jury that day.
Yeah. But no real criminal indictment and taken to court.
But he was told that the U.S.M. it wasn't the U.S.M. it was Mississippi Southern College and then went to the university.
And what they... Clyde was a person who believed in the goodness of mankind.
Do you know his story from when it was happening?
Yes, I know his story. I knew him personally. I worked where he brought eggs.
Not every day he would bring in flights of eggs, box of crates of eggs.
I worked on a little restaurant on Mobile Street.
And the day he came in, there were several gentlemen. They would meet at Smith-Trucks' door.
The leaders.
And they tried to talk him out of coming out here each time that last time he came, he came alone.
Is that the Black leadership?
Yes. They tried to talk him out of them.
Now, there were conversations behind the scenes with Dr. McCain, Mr. Berger,
who was the Black principal, if I have to identify people, Black or White,
who was the Black principal over in Rowan.
He and Mr. Roy, who was a principal at Ureca, Anthony,
they wanted a Black junior college put here in Hattiesburg.
So, in a way they would sell outs to me.
And of course, I graduated with one of Mr. Berger's sons.
And I know they loved their dad, they loved their mom.
But to me, they were sell outs.
We needed access. This was a state-run school with state taxes.
We needed to be able to go here just like everyone else.
And so they tried to talk Mr. Knauer out of them?
From coming out here alone.
Oh, yes. Oh, yes. They talked to a client several times.
I think it's documented in the Sovereignty Commission.
It's certainly documented in some of the other papers.
So, Dr. McCain played the politics,
allowed Ole Miss to be the first one with James Marinette.
And since we were girls, girls,
Dr. Lucas calls us angels,
but Dr. McCain had a few other choice words I'm sure.
Because he belonged to the John Birch Society.
And that's just the same as the client.
So, when we came to campus, I give all credit to Clyde.
I mean, that was in the late 50s. We came mid-60.
And the good people who would supply food to me
and helped us and paid to missions, stuff like that,
elained our both come from poverty.
And there were many days we'd walked back and forth
from the other side of town to here.
I want to follow up on some of what you said,
but Miss Smith, you nodded your head too.
You know Mr. Kenyle?
Sure did.
I knew him in a different way.
I knew of him when he was arrested,
and he was in the jail, and he was sick.
At that time, they had Dr. Willis Walker, a white doctor,
and the moan brothers who were very instrumental
in double-ICP and sending her
and the other young lady just sovened
and the two young ladies were carrying care
and my son had integrated public schools.
I knew him because Mr. Moins wanted him to see
I wanted to have some position, which was my husband.
He checked him and examined him
and explained to them that he needed a worker.
You know?
This is when he's at parchment?
This was when he was in the Forest County jail.
This was when I first met him,
Forest County jail.
They later, I think, they still sent him on parchment.
They later, when they did check him out,
it was too late.
He had cancer.
So you think he already had it?
He had it there.
He had the symptoms, but he knew that he had to work him up.
They could have sent him to the medical center,
to Jackson.
But I gave him hard labor.
They did.
They just did him so well.
But we tried to keep over him,
but you know what?
That was his mission.
God had to free his people.
And the way I see it,
those things that happened to me,
putting me where the movement was happening.
When I first met Ray Lani,
I met Ray Lani at the end of the way,
C.P. meeting in 1929.
So she was a little secretary.
So we had to go up to her stairs down the Moean Street.
And a lot of people say,
oh, she didn't live here.
She wouldn't live.
But that's not true.
I've always known her being a fighter.
I've been a fighter that'll stand up by herself.
She don't need a grouse.
You know, so God has put some of us on this earth as a mission.
We have to thank Clack and Dar for his mission.
Not everybody's going to know about Mr. Canard.
So can you explain the backstory of what happened with him?
There's some I can tell you and some I can't.
Not in any of them.
He lived outside on the north side of Hadithworth's small community
called Macedonia.
Oh, well, that Kelly settlement.
Kelly settlement.
But I'm not the buddy between here and the airport.
So you were going to tell us about Mr. Canard?
Mr. Canard had come to Hadithworth to help his mother.
His father died.
And they had a chicken farm.
They raised bitties, small baby chickens,
up to a certain size.
And then they went off to the feed stores.
And it depended on the size when they got bought by home.
And he had come out here total of three times.
But when he started and the conversations were going on between McCain,
the governor and might have had Johnson all the way back then
when they started, by going to Johnson.
Was it Governor Coleman?
No, I don't think so.
It was just before Ross Bonnetto.
I think he might have been Governor Coleman.
Well, whatever one it was, there was conversation going on.
And as I said, I knew a client because he brought eggs into what we call fat sketch
and it was one of the restaurants right next to Smith-Juckstown.
Yeah, it was Smith in the beginning.
Smith-Juckstown.
And over the years, I graduated in 59.
That was the year.
And I think that was at the last year he came out here.
And he came along and they arrested him.
Eventually, at one time it was whiskey in the car, at one time it was something else.
And then it was he stole chicken feed.
Now the story about the chicken feed.
A friend of his worked at one of the feed stores.
And the chicken feed came in 100 pound bags.
So sometimes the bags on the bottom would get damp and they wouldn't sell that.
They would throw it out.
So he would sweep it up and re-bag it.
Mr. Canard's friend.
Friend.
Mr. Canard didn't work there.
Mr. Canard worked on his farm and sold eggs and chickens, I guess, on the table.
I don't...
The man at the time, he wasn't...
I mean, he's my age.
We were the same age.
Robert.
Robert, Robert, Robert.
It was all this last time.
I think of it.
Anyway, he would get fired by the time he was fired.
By the time he would gather together 500 pounds, five bags, he would take it to Clyde
because all the chicken feed places, all the feed houses refused to sell chicken feed to it.
They figured that would run him out of business.
And that's because he was trying to go to sov.
Because he was trying to go to sov.
So they were doing, you know, pressuring it.
And then he was arrested.
And it was just...
It was very devastating for me to see what supposed to be the law do such a terrible thing.
And Mr. JC Fairley and I tried...
We didn't.
We didn't try.
We did.
Mr. Fairley got in touch with Dick Gregory and Charles Evers who was in Chicago.
Charles Evers was Mekka's brother.
Mekka Evers brother who was killed in Jackson, Mississippi.
They met us at the airport in Jackson, a private plane.
It was paid for by Dick Gregory.
And we talked Mr. Roberts.
Was this the last thing?
Anyway, we talked him into going and telling the truth.
Because if you look at the court case, it's a comedy.
Mr. Roberts, did you say that Clyde told you to steal our chicken feed?
Yes, sir.
He did.
He was 19.
He was very frightened, scared to death a wife of him.
And just said whatever that lawyer said to say, he said.
And he got seven years.
Now, there are some things I had to leave out of that.
But he is still living.
He goes to Shady Grove back to church.
And Jerry Mitchell, out of Jackson with the Clarion Ledger,
and I got together and he'll tell you if you email him.
And brought the man to my house.
And he told us that story.
So there was never any stealing involved.
They still say Clyde cannot want to jail for stealing.
He didn't.
He went to jail because he tried to come to the center.
You mentioned Mr. Fairly?
Mr. JC Fairly.
And he was president of NAACP then, is that what?
At that time, yes.
Mr. Damon was before Mr. Fairly.
And then, Mr. Smith, did you have parts you wanted to add about Mr. Knives?
How you doing?
Well, I think so, yes.
I knew him because NAACP was happening.
And that's who was really the backbone of everything.
Integrating the public accommodations, voting, and everything.
The reason that you had this summer of 1964,
because how this bird was like a mecker of people that you had a group of men in the 1950s
had filed a suit to keep the right to register vote in the 1950s.
You had a group that had always fought for their rights.
And we've had a branch in NAACP branch here since 1946.
So the people came because it was safe.
That's why you had so many people to come down.
And sometimes it's sad.
And so I'll never forget this little answer,
Judge from Pennsylvania, had said,
if it's not local, it's not real.
So we were not writers.
We didn't come down here representing churches, organizations.
We weren't documented in history.
We were just doing it because we wanted our rights.
And in fact, I have a kind of feeling about that.
You know, for people coming in to profit from what the people did,
a lot of times they don't even get recognition for it.
And it's kind of sad thing because the local people haven't gotten recognition.
They couldn't lose their lives.
They burned churches, home, ran them out of time.
Like they threatened us.
They were terrorists.
You know, they threatened many people.
And they'd read through that.
They didn't, after two weeks or three weeks, they didn't go back home.
And then I'm a traveler.
So this friend of mine, who was a journalist, who stayed with me.
I went to visit her and then fell in love with your pencil, right?
The first thing I wanted to know was kind of community.
She lived in a gay community.
No integrated church.
No integrated school.
But she was down here fighting our calls.
And she needed to be home fighting their calls.
So it just bothered me the double standards.
So it stuck with me.
If it's not local, it's not real.
I see acts of, you know, segregation right now on double standards.
I want to attack it.
I want to get rid of it because it shouldn't be.
We are in America.
You know, and I don't have any problems being black.
I appreciate the black culture.
They made me what I am.
You know, they made me strong.
Not bitter, but wanting to get rid of the problem.
I want to be like everybody else.
I taught my children that.
Everybody around me, I want to be the black people accepted me.
Because unlike her, I have more cultures than me.
In this, I have white, black, Spanish.
And I'm one-four for each one of those.
So I was up there and getting in the casino.
And somebody told me that I could get me, they had some money up there for me.
I had to do it.
I could get some because I'm one-four.
But I'm one-four.
Oh my goodness.
You have to go up there to apply.
That's what they do.
I talk to the chief before they got to lead the chief.
And then I talk to all about that.
I say, you know, I'm not trying to profit on for that.
I just want everybody to be treated equal.
We have equal rights.
We are the only race that came here against our wishes, as slaves.
I don't want to be bitter about that.
Most people were trying to make money.
And the folks who had them on their ship,
they cleaned them up and they started integration on their ship.
How could you have such double standards?
How could you hate people and you have sex with them and families by?
How could you do that?
How could you own them behind the scenes and when you get with someone else,
you can't own them.
You can't live through that.
And when we got us, I'm not so proud of it.
He called himself a black president.
Because of all the people.
When did he do that?
He's a black president.
He'll mind himself with the black president.
Oh, oh, you mean, okay.
A mama.
He had no choice.
If he did, no.
He did.
He's my 20th.
I'm going to tell you what I'm like.
No matter what they do to him,
he doesn't come out with bitterness.
He come out giving him a lesson.
And sometimes they, what they do to him,
I want to go in my self-defense mode.
I want to go in and defend it.
Do something to him.
You ought to be shy, you know.
This is the crescent of the best, right?
This respect in our president.
But for once, we have a man in there that represents us.
So in America, everybody's representing.
We have a baratial president.
And it's certainly not the color issue.
Yes, ma'am.
Because Dr. Carter is a Carter?
Yeah.
I wouldn't vote for Dr. Carter if he was running for dog catcher.
He's a good surgeon.
But he doesn't even do that anymore.
So you can't call him a good surgeon anymore.
He might have been a good surgeon.
Can I circle back with Pran?
Sure.
We mentioned Charles Evers and Dick Gregory
and Brandon the Plain Dejaxon.
Was that where Mr. Canard was released at the very end?
No, we were trying to get the boy who was the state witness
to tell the truth.
To tell the truth.
And he was so afraid.
We did get him to Chicago.
And they took him out to dinner.
And he said they had, they put this big stake in front of him.
But there was a white woman sitting next to him.
He couldn't eat the stake.
He said I couldn't swallow with his white woman sitting next to me.
And he left the group with the excuse he had to go to the bathroom
or something and left the group and found his way back to Hattiesburg.
He was scared to death.
And all these years he's still.
We have a Clyde Canard Day here on campus.
We have a Clyde Canard Day in Merrimagdalene Church
where he is buried.
And he goes to Shady Grove
where there's some very strong people that come out of Shady Grove.
Mr. Damon was one of them.
He's never, never talked about it.
Now is that out of fear still or is that out of shame
that he didn't stand up like a man?
I would have probably been dead.
I think I was born, as you say, with mission.
I quit school and got the principal fired when I was four and a half
in Mount Carmel, Mississippi.
Because he hit me four times along with three other students
for going in the book house and we didn't go in the book house.
And I kept telling him, we weren't the ones that went in the book house.
It was those other children that ran when you came.
But he called the assembly and with four of us, little tots,
pre-primer they call it, pre-primer, where you read,
we willy-winkel.
I was reading and four and a half so they said,
let her go to school, two went to school and he went with me.
And when I got my four legs I walked down little three steps
off the stage and just kept walking and he screamed,
a young lady come back here and sit down.
And I turned around and I said, I'm going home and tell my daddy.
And they called the meeting at the church that night and he was fired
because he was wrong.
I don't care what your color is, you're wrong, you're wrong.
So I guess that must have been a really lesson for you.
Let me you stood up for yourself and then you have back to that.
I've always stood up for myself.
My great grandmother, who on my daddy side told the story,
her, she had two boys who were Pullman porters.
They fought or philip, but it's Randolph.
Philip, he ran off, I think it is.
A philip, Randolph.
She would get a pass, the family would get a pass and she would go
somewhere different, California, Washington state,
every year following the Federated Women's Club.
And they would have a national convention and she was one of those
who could afford to go because she had the pass.
And she said this conductor was taking her ticket and call her Amy.
And she said she turned and looked at him and said,
you know, I don't know you.
I don't know your mother and I don't know your father.
I'm not sister to either one of them.
So how am I your Amy?
So I come up, there was a shotgun at the door.
It wasn't the shotgun you hunted for food and nobody
was to come through that door after your family.
Did you know that?
I learned to shoot.
You didn't move in the country.
And not know how to shoot.
My mother hunted.
And yet I'm a person against guns.
And the NRA is a shameful part of America.
I love guns.
Well, I don't, there's one in the house but it's an antique.
I would shoot it, probably shoot me.
I believe in the certificates.
You know, some things, but you know, and I understand my mission.
I understand people who've been inflicted with fear.
It's engraved in them.
So in forgiving people, you gotta understand them.
We were blessed to have been born with a mission.
Most people don't have it.
That's fine.
I'm very forgiving.
See, you didn't ask to be born white.
I didn't ask to be born mixed.
But we're God's children.
I don't want to blame anyone but what somebody else's scenes were doing that day.
And we're gonna get along.
We're gonna have to learn to work with everyone.
Because the massive of the people are not like us.
They need us to help them.
And I want to help them.
That's why in our home up there, my niece, they right next door to me,
there's a gun in their room for the following, you know,
things like them there, taking all they found,
and the two leg of ones too.
Because you never know what people are up to.
And then when you're down in those woods, and we live in a lane,
it's very proud.
You don't know who else coming from the back of the woods.
So they know that we defend ourselves.
Yes.
So, I'm like most people, I'd like gods.
I'm not gonna have a gun.
I don't have a people drug.
I don't want to be on my rack.
You know, I don't want to do that.
But I have it for a purpose.
I think you have a right to defend yourself.
Because if you didn't, I wouldn't be living today.
You know, people know that we believe we have gods.
We would defend our property.
In the house of a shot at in the movement.
Yes.
1916.
There was so much going on prior to 1964.
I left here in 1966, Mr. Damard died January 10th, 1966.
I finished school here in 1966 and got a scholarship
to St. John's Episcopal School in Nursing in New York City.
But before 1964, we had, gosh, the hotel downtown, far as hotel, we had had Judge Higgin
Muffin was the speaker. We had integrated that. We had gone to a hotel for lunch or breakfast
or something, you know, 49. And I was stealth. Now, you know the word stealth. You're doing
things but you're hiding as you do it. I was the first person hired at the telephone
company. They put me on nights and I had no one to keep my children at night. My husband
was mentally ill and not with me anymore. And I couldn't take a job where I had no
one to take care of my children. So I told them I couldn't take it. But I had made that
first step, which meant other people made stepped up. Joyce, Joyce, born, brown, who
is now a Yarnboro, stepped up and went and got a job. And that was her job, her whole
life. She worked at the telephone company. I was the first one hired by series. Now, this
was with the knowing of the NAACP, somebody had to know where you were. So we knew that
there was someone in the group that would tell everything. So there was just maybe four
or five of us who would plan to do things. And there was a place for everyone. Many of
the people who did things are dead and gone. We'll never, we'll never get any recognition.
The first clerk hired at Sears. They put me in shipping and receiving. So nobody had
to look at me. But one day the candy girl didn't come in. They, I don't know if you remember
Sears and they had a little candy shop, a little candy place in the middle of the store.
The candy girl didn't come in. So the cleanup lady was asking, she worked at Sears out
here after they moved it to them all. She retired from there. They asked her, you think you
can sell candy? So I had made a step in which opened up a place. And for other people,
I was the first one hired by Big Yank, which made clothes. Yeah, they wore jeans, jeans
and shared work clothes. And we went to the permanent press. They had 400 women working,
sewing, cutting and sewing. They refused to work with blacks. I bugged them down at the
unemployment office to the point of climbing across the man's desk and getting right
up in his face. I know there's a job up in here somewhere for me, other than Miss Anne's
kitchen or working on a restaurant. And when you work on a restaurant, you couldn't
even work out in the, where the tables were. If you did, you only bust tables and you
had to do that with gloves, white gloves. They gave the federal book to me. And that's
what woke me up to the fact that I need some more education. I had a high school diploma,
but that was all. And I had had three babies. So when I went to Big Yank, they finally hired
me. And they sent me back up for them. I'm walking. I know I don't have a car. There's no
buses going back from Big Yank over the Walnut Street without a unemployment office while.
They finally hired me. And the floor walker said, my supervisor said, go out and find,
you know, say a three-other gal that worked with you because we're going to have to put
you on evenings. The other ladies won't work with you. 400. Well, my plan I did when I got
three others. They ran a whole shift with a floor walker, a supervisor. And they had one
gentleman who ran this heating machine that the clothes went through to become permanent
press. And we got in this, and we went and joined their magma made it clothing in, which was
right down the street. It's Korean church right now. We had this competition going. We will
press everything you, you, so. And on the big shoot coming from upstairs down and we'd walk in
and we'd see all these shirts and bundles of 25, 50, whatever they were. They couldn't sew enough
shirts during the day. But we got learned how to run those machines. And the floor walker told me,
you're, your machine is number one, but you too short to run that machine. And I started looking
around and said, you have a little box stepped up on that little box. We got used to doing what we
had to do to those shirts. I was the first one, the handle, I pressed the body and then the
collars and the shirts and in the last fourth girl pinned them with the paper that they put in the
cardboard. We got so good. The rule under the union was if you finished your piecework before the
eight hours, you could still get paid for eight hours, believe. They couldn't sew enough shirts to
keep us there more than six eight hours. And we just tried out. And it leveled the clock at night.
And I had walked home and I walked into shadows because you didn't want to be out in the light
with somebody to continue to get. But they definitely would.
You mentioned that one and it was murdered that that really was shot or you could check it was
your first exposure, I guess. It was, it tipped me that I was different. And that Mississippi and other
places, even Chicago, was a place that maybe you should be afraid. And that people
hated you. I had gone to a church with my mother and it was a table similar to this and we
were sitting over here and a little boy, about four, five years old maybe. He crawled underneath
and he'd get right there and he'd look up at me and say, I think I think I know the other women who
were all white besides me and my mother at that table heard that child. They never said a word to him.
That was in Chicago. And I was in Chicago. I picked up Jet Magazine and it wasn't on the
front cover. Was it the mid-the center phone? What you ever wanted was. He was in the casket.
And it frighten me so much. I threw the, threw down the magazine, the Jet Magazine. It ran out of
the store. It ran all the way home. And I said, Mama, they killed the boy in Mississippi.
For Mama, it wasn't new. It wasn't that it wasn't news. She wasn't affected. But it set me,
it affected me so much. I said, and Mama had always said, if they did anything to one of my
boys and my husband, I would get jobs at nursing homes and hospitals and I would poison up a lot of
people. So my family, I'd grown up when I was in the country with the shotgun sitting there,
you protected your family. My mother and I always said, they better not do anything to one of my boys.
And to see this child having that done because I always said, you wouldn't take my grandchild out
of my house. They had to take me that night. But they lied. Or maybe the family was afraid
the grandparents or whatever it was. But they wouldn't have gotten one of my brothers out of the
house unless they'd killed everyone in the house. We had done many, many things. Her husband
built a clinic here in Hattiesburg. The building is still there. He built the clinic because he
was a black doctor. And the hospital, far general hospital, it was called Methodist Hospital. It's
now merit-wessling out on 98. They would, if he had a client that needed to go into the hospital,
he had to turn them over to a white doctor. That's how bad it was. When I, all three of my babies
were born at first, you know, I don't know about yours. Just one. The charity hospital was up in
Laurel. And it was in the basement. You had to walk through the furnace room and the laundry stuff
to get to where the club folks were. And you could have TB, gunshot, babies, born. Everything was
down there in that dark, dingy basement with no light. Farge general, there was a floor.
It's now a hallway on the way. Yes, now a hallway on the backside of the cafeteria.
Everyone was put there. Because my mother was who she was, now let's see,
Feltz, who was a white doctor at Hattiesburg Clinic with our physician. And he would give us a
five o'clock appointment. So we didn't have to go in that little back room and sit in the
week until they saw all the white pages. You said because your mother was who she was,
can you be a white father and a black mother. So the doctor was willing to give her a little
privilege. She had, we got privileges. Now, Bill Thacker, Dr. Thacker was our dentist.
His house is on the corner of Broadway and one side side street. It's right across
and where the Catholic High School is right now. Some big, brick fence around that house.
And Bill Thacker, his wife, went to the church until she died where I go now.
And I asked Bill, I said, Bill, why did you all put that big brick wall around your house?
They had two girls and the clan had threatened them. They were going to kidnap those girls
and kill them because he took black patients.
We have been terrorized for as long as we've been here.
We have been fighting this fight for as long as we've been here.
It goes on today. You said that your mother always said that if anybody did anything to her
songs or her songs, she was going to get revenge. She was going to self defense.
She was more worried about the males and the family.
We couldn't go into a restaurant and go to the bathroom or anything like that downtown here.
You couldn't go to a hotel. But you could get a job when your man had, could, it was different.
Can you explain it for people that didn't experience it?
Oh gosh. You know what I'm asking?
Like your daddy, he worked the farm or hard out to work for somebody's wife.
All right. My daddy wasn't a carpenter. When he went into the Navy,
he was one of those Mississippians who not only could read but write and he had beautiful handwriting.
So he was trained to be a teacher in service, an instructor they called them in service.
And they only sent people that could boost their numbers because most whites out of
Mississippi at that time and it's well documented. Could not read right.
What did the military have in trouble right?
Oh yeah.
That weren't educated enough.
And do you know we're back to that now?
Especially out of the state of Mississippi, they have a problem recruiting because there's
so many people who can't, young men who can't read or write.
They might have finished school or got a GED.
They're two types of GEDs. I didn't realize that.
There's just one where you attend. You got a certificate of attendance
and one where you got a high school diploma.
I think that's a new development isn't it?
It's been a long time.
We just didn't know it.
Okay. Because I, yeah, I don't know about that reason.
You can see how their funds in when they're certain age, you know, 18, I think 20.
They might go to 20.
Well, they got to get them out of school.
So they just pass them whether they really passed or not.
And then they try to put them in vocation on school.
That's the whole idea.
But you have to read to get it even into a vocation.
Well, they had a system.
And one time.
And then what?
But now many companies cannot get workers who can read and who can write.
And yes, they, it's like jail.
Jail has become a business.
As Jeanette stated, long before the students and the freedom writers came to town,
a came to Mississippi in the south.
We were fighting.
And we're very successful.
I was wondering if you all could tell me about the early end of LACP.
Because you were both involved with that, right?
She, you know, she went on the nursing school.
We were very active on all levels.
Because we're so active with the largest member in the state.
Life members.
And in my resume, that's what I dealt with.
And I touched on that.
So because of our activities,
and we were known for us county, was a fighting county.
That's why everybody came here.
And like I was saying, it's just amazing how they came here.
And some of the stories and books that are read.
Should be the stories of the people they stay in with.
Well, it's a shame that they didn't even give them credit for it.
As if they just came here,
split us on another thing to bother me more than anything else.
They had funds to help them.
They never gave them anything on groceries.
You know, just, you know, it was just a transfer like they were.
Going to Africa, to help Africa.
But when you came home,
or you didn't really help them.
Because you were eating their food.
You know, I know what I fed them.
You know, and there was, but we had to catch a nine-on-one mystery.
Miss Campbell, Miss Farley, and her sister,
Miss Boyd and myself, I was down to time to cook.
That's how I learned to cook.
I think you're holding it.
So was this during the summer, so you all had to catch it?
This was before.
Was this when the first year of the year?
From 62, from the minister's started in 61.
61, that's right.
You're right.
So you're out, so that was like cooking for the registration?
For the workers, they were hungry.
You know, because we knew that the people,
if they housed them,
and they keep them safe, and nobody bombed the house,
they probably would,
the cops could have been destroyed.
They couldn't have lost a lot of things
by just helping no civil rights workers.
So we had to organize in the community.
You had, the churches were so wonderful.
You had summer school, vacation,
my other school,
and they were cooking at the church.
So what we did, the churches gave us food
that we began to cook over their own mobiles street.
They feed the workers.
So you're saying we, and we organize, right?
No.
And you, can you, so we then ACP,
we, okay, so the NAACP,
even though we married and became co-founder,
the NAACP led.
Can I ask, when did you all first learn about the NAACP?
Do you remember?
I was only about it all my life.
Did was your family members?
They were our members.
Because we were in the culture that you had
with Brad's out there.
But the Laurel had a branch, Dr. Murph.
We just never joined.
But we supported and we gave them money.
You know, we always do what they feed the farm dry.
We always gave them money.
Was that true for your family too?
It was, I learned that one of my grandmothers,
both my grandmothers,
they had stuck their receipts at cheap,
the least expensive one used to be $15.
Ten.
Their receipts were stuck in the Bible.
Right.
And I was going through their Bibles.
And that time I found out they were members of the NAACP.
You know, in Claymore, they used to burn those cards when they were come.
Oh.
Because they were afraid.
That's how I'm going to get them.
I don't think my grandmother was too afraid of the police.
And I wasn't afraid of the police.
We were.
And now, now, of course, I was just plain listed as crazy.
You know, I did think.
But you know what happened?
Because I was crazy.
Um, Jones kind of being one of those places where the clan was.
See, the clan was like this.
They would go to other communities and tear right at them.
They wouldn't kill in their own community.
They were scared to come out there in Jones County.
Because we knew who were behind them sheets.
We knew who they were.
So my grandfather, we were being so, so meeting.
And how did he put on his sheet?
And went up there and ran all up up there.
Because you couldn't tell him because he was a mixture of white and anything.
So he didn't feel treating the clan.
He said, you know, I know you.
He pulled on them sheets all day.
And they were going, they were getting ready to go cut down and forest county.
And they're ready to see people down here.
Because they had so many kinfongs up there.
They didn't want to kill it on the phone.
But it's just amazing how terrorists think.
You know, and those are the same people
that where we live, my father's people, we're dealing with the muskows.
We would all of them.
Once you, the muskows came to, they came to a joint new knight's deserters.
Now there was a, it's not the same as Governor Musgrove.
That one, because.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, he did tell that to me.
Did he tell you that?
Yeah.
He did.
Because I was a campaigning for him in one time.
Musgrove was all right.
Well, what happened?
You know, we were all up there in the meeting with him.
And, you know, you know, see, like I say, you were terrorized.
The reason that I survived, I know my people claimed me.
Our new knight is the father on my grandfather's birth certificate.
They claim the children they gave him life.
So that's how I survived.
I don't have to worry about who I am.
They will tell you, oh, that's my cousin.
So they would sort of put the little protection out?
Yeah.
You know, my students, yeah, there were certain people you did not mess with.
Because they had white kin.
Because their, their daddies and their grandaddies were who they were.
New would kill them.
If he messed with any, in his people, people killed.
Well, there's a poster.
We had it here during one event.
Back, let me see, I first got the poster.
It was just a fire.
Two, four, six, about six pages, you know, folded in tri-fold.
And that's when I learned that my grandfather had gone to register to vote.
When we started registering down to a fair and only.
Probably.
Yeah.
Can you say his full name for the record?
Lee Val Graves.
And Lee L-E-E V-A-L Graves, G-R-A-V-E-S.
Yeah.
Lee Val Graves.
So you found the record that he had gone for?
Well, it was a picture.
Oh, no, no.
So I'm not saying that the fire to me from Washington, D.C.,
they had a big conference in Washington.
And he and another guy were standing there at Theran Lin's counter.
The same counter I had gone to answer my Constitution question.
I was registered first.
I was the youngest.
I think I was the youngest one in the register for our scone.
When I got to be 21, I went down there.
But at that time.
You were done with them.
I can, was it you say?
I was more than 41.
So it was 6162.
But I was registered in 61.
See, I'm OK.
I'm my whole of them shit.
I was born in 1840.
Tell us what it was like to go to register.
Oh, I had three big men at my back.
Who did you have?
Mr. JC Ferreland.
Mr. James Bourne.
And Mr. Vernon Damer.
Is that Mr. Bourne as he can to Miss Conn?
No, Bull.
I'm sorry.
You had time to go pegging.
Mr. Goon.
No, I missed it.
So you said it was Mr. Bourne?
James Bourne.
Mr. Farley.
JC Ferreland.
Close the bill.
And Mr. Damer.
So they came with you when you...
I said, standing right at my back.
See, Theran Lin, I don't know if you've ever seen a picture of him.
But please describe him for us.
Really fun.
Huge guy.
About like this.
About six, three, four.
But he had the tiny little heads.
I went a huge first with the tiny little head.
And he would walk back and forth and he would say,
this is your question.
Can you answer this constitutional question?
And I wrote that.
I wrote that.
You know, Mrs. James had prepared us well on how on the Constitution.
And I wrote and I wrote, finally he walks up and takes it and says,
and handed it to a clerk and said, she passed.
He didn't even read it.
When you said you were well prepared, was that your school teacher?
School teacher.
It's Marjorie James with our world history teacher.
And she did a lot with us knowing about the Constitution and things like that.
Was she specifically trying to prepare you to register with that part of teaching?
No, no.
That was just part of Mrs. James' teaching.
In fact, she was one of those teachers
when they, quote, unquote, integrated the school.
They pulled her out of the black school and sent her over to the white school
because she was a good teacher.
And you know, there was a law on the book that I don't know if it's still there.
And I say, people should look to see.
I should look to see if it's still there.
If there was something that you wanted to do that wasn't taught in Mississippi,
you could be sitting out of the state in the state with Peyton DeVille.
Well,
I'll just say that a record, this is before Brown, and this is when they were trying to avoid
a very sacred gate in the school.
Yes.
And they thought that way they could avoid the whole separate place.
That's when I was in the medical school.
Did he?
No, I'm not.
Really?
I didn't know about it.
Did he go to the school?
Well, he thought he was, but his grandfather was Jewish,
and they really had sent him to school.
We didn't know that until after we were married.
He was trying to pay his loan back, and they tell him, you don't have a loan.
So he came down here with a type of parish because he was trying to pay all state in Mississippi.
And there was such a need for medical care,
until he just stayed.
Dr. Barrett, he can take it.
He had to go back to Chicago.
Where was your husband from?
His from Memphis.
Memphis?
And so he came here to pay off his school?
Hello from Tennessee.
And then stayed.
So did he go to my Harry?
He went to my Harry.
And it's just a, and now that we're talking about him, it's amazing.
When he first came, he was trying to take the license.
He had his license.
And then he had to go up on the freight elevator.
But when he got up in there, he took tests with everybody else.
He said, he would determine when he came back.
He will integrate far as them.
That was County Hospital.
He made a complaint with H.U.W.
He was going to integrate Methodist.
He was going to integrate them in Dr's office.
Just as soon as they started taking care, taking Medicare,
can have federal money.
He was going to integrate everything.
And basically that's what he did.
Did he ever work with the Medical Committee on Human Rights?
Is that what it's called?
It was some of the doctors that came into the Civil Rights Movement.
Dr. Smith?
I'll be happy.
You remember, I remember.
Marion Wright, she was part of that group.
I don't know if he did or not because he was so busy.
He was thinking about this.
I think it's something he had to do.
When he was working so hard, he eventually became the president of the end of the lengthy.
But I wasn't here then.
But before I left, he was busy delivering babies.
Because in that clinic, as she said, babies were born there.
When we got head start, and that's a whole another story,
I sent a busload of children, the Lady Bird Johnson,
to Washington, to keep until we got head start.
They kept saying we were coming to this movement.
And I made the comment one night to Robert Beach.
We were on the phone.
And I said, Robert, I'm having a hard time here.
I don't have a car, some days I don't have money to get on the bus.
And I have no money to put my children in daycare.
I said, and a few daycare.
You know that, John?
John, John, they were out of business.
And I didn't have the money.
I said, you know what?
I ought to send them to Washington.
If I had the money, I could send them to the White House.
Because she had maids and cooks, and it's a big house.
And Lady Bird could take care of them.
And he called back the next day.
And I still don't know where that money came from.
He called back the next day and said,
Rilani, can you, were you serious about sending your children
to the White House?
I said, yeah, I was serious, but he said,
can you get enough children to fill up a greyhound blast?
I said to go to Washington.
He said, yeah.
He said, and I need women to go with them to take care of the children.
Because they were preschoolers.
They were 500.
And it was January.
And we sent those poor children to Washington, DC,
without caps and gloves and hats and it slowed.
And someone on that end, women met those children
with the proper clothing and boots and stuff.
And I have a picture of my, only two of them went.
Because Timothy was in school over the evening sitting on the floor
of the House of Representatives.
But we sent a busload of children.
We got head start after that.
And I was a resource teacher for head start.
Excuse me, was it in Mississippi already?
Was CDGM in here?
Was that in the city?
No, that was before.
That was before.
We were doing a whole lot of things before.
The one thing I learned from the students and people coming in.
I don't have anything really bad to say.
I learned that not all White people were bad.
They're not.
Up until then, they were devils.
They would excuse me.
They would stick it in any hole.
That's what I thought.
They were saying that people.
They needed to be converted.
But we did so much.
I give them credit.
I learned from them that not all people are bad.
But as she said, they came for an experience.
Now, there were some people who went back and did some wonderful things.
A Jill Wakeman, who stayed with that lady that lived on the corner,
Tempton and some street over the anystruzel.
Jill Wakeman was her maiden name.
She married.
But she still goes on to Jill Wakeman.
If you look her up on anyhoo.com.
She opened the biggest suit kitchen.
It's still running in San Francisco, I believe.
They had her on 60 minutes or 48 hours or something like that.
She and a girl of Chinese extraction.
Her name was Marion.
Marion.
Okay, remember?
I spent so long.
But Jill, I won't forget because Jill sent $10 in an envelope to me.
The two and a half years I was in school in New York.
And that's what I lived on in New York City.
$10 a month.
And she opened this food kitchen and it's still one of the biggest food
kitchens in America.
The reason I asked about the medical committee for human rights was
when you mentioned that your husband was determined to integrate those hospitals.
Because I can't remember which law it was.
But one of those laws that was passed as part of the war on poverty was bringing the
fellow Danny into the hospital.
And they were using that as the leverage.
And so I just wondered if he might have had any contact with him over any of the time.
Well, they were friends and he worked with him, Dr. Mason, Dr. Smith, and I.
They had an organization among themselves.
Because there was no one group.
I see my husband, the people in law were wonderful.
They had a black hospital.
He transferred his patients up there.
That's how he met me.
And what was the hospital inside?
I think the Netherlands hospital up there long.
I didn't know about it.
That's a black heart wonderful.
My daddy and my uncle had built a church in Luister and they contacted pneumonia.
So my first cousin and I were down for the dedication of the church.
So these were black doctors were there.
And my husband was single and the other one was married.
So I thought he was, I was on my way to Delaware University.
And I wasn't looking for no husband.
So my husband told my daddy, not that's the one I want.
So he said, no, he said what?
He came out with my first cousin from so-so.
T-9 in Pasquale.
That's how they recruited me.
So anyway, he'd T-8 check.
I said, oh, I'm so glad you came.
You can take my daddy.
My daddy and pneumonia put him dad in the hospital.
And so he was cordoned me through my daddy.
Because my husband-
So was your daddy coming in trouble at the end of the year?
No, my daddy was trying to get me married off.
Well, you didn't talk to the girl first.
You didn't talk to the family.
So he was just boasted me up and I heard him and they say,
well, if you get hurt, you get the right one.
That's what you're doing, you say?
She might be young, but she's very mature.
She's been taking care of my business and stuff.
She been father when she was born.
So things like that, I'm listening to him talking about me.
So that's how I met him.
And then I finally used a very nice person.
You know, and I really liked him.
And I said, thank my daddy for finding me a husband.
So did you still go off to build him?
No, I didn't.
I got married within four months.
Did you miss going off to build him?
Not really, because you know, education is a continuing thing.
You don't have to have those letters to know that you are a sponge,
that you learn and everything come through your way.
And my husband made me see that then.
I went down to William Gariford, law, and I had three little children.
And it was just hard on me.